everything about that was right was the
right producer in the right studio with
the right song that we had written with
the right players
everything about it was just perfect and
um you know it's just one of those
things
now obviously it didn't sound this good
when you guys are
kind of messing around getting it going
getting the song going like all these
things were produced right it was much
more simple produced by areth Martin one
of the world's great producers one of
you know one of the greatest producers
of all time uh but that's Bernard Purdy
playing drums one of the you know
probably one of the greatest r b
drummers of all time
um you know it's just like I said it was
The Perfect Storm it was the right
people the right circumstance and we had
written the right song and at first it
was just your guitars and singing the
song that's it well when we when we
wrote it it was um I was playing
acoustic guitar Daryl was playing
electric piano and that's how we wrote
it we wrote it in about an hour and a
half you wrote that song in an hour and
a half oh yeah if that if that I had I
had gotten stood up on a date uh for New
Year's Eve and
um so while I was sitting in the
apartment by myself
I just picked up the guitar and I
thought well she's not coming she's
never got me she and I said well she's
gone and I started doing this like folky
like Cat Stevens kind of thing
um and it was like she's gone and
um I was kind of messing around with
that for a while and then the next day
uh Daryl came back to the house to the
apartment because we were sharing an
apartment and uh I played it for him and
he sat down at the piano and he said oh
that's cool and he started going going
which is the piano riff that you hear
from the song and we just wrote it and
we just looked around the apartment and
I remember like you know in the course
of writing just walking into the
bathroom and then it was toothbrush you
know hanging on the stand or whatever
yeah it's all you know frayed and you
know I probably I probably was using the
same toothbrush for four years or
something but um uh and it was just that
you know just taking these you know
snapshots of Life of loss and loneliness
and just putting it together the right
way you know and so you go back and
forth like you did on on numerous songs
where you'd come up with a little line
and you go how about this and you just
go back and forth with like different
yeah yeah yeah exactly
um and I you know I can't remember you
know who who came up with it but it
doesn't really doesn't matter at this
point but that that line everybody's
high on consolation
that's like I mean you think about that
line
that's a really good line yeah you know
and that was that was the kickoff once
once that line that that's the beginning
of the song was like okay we now we know
what this is about let's go and you know
we just wrote it you know what else
could have worked because I always used
to mess up the lines and I'd sing it
everybody's high on Constellation oh I
know and that's what everybody thought
it was of course of course it's like
astrology
just just like yeah yeah that was well
we were hippies so you know maybe
astrology thing could have worked but
constellation's way better
but you know just like people think it's
kiss on my lips it's kiss on my lips
it's like it's not your kiss is not not
on my lips your kisses on the list of
the best things in life it doesn't
necessarily it is the best thing
I love that you're talking about this
because it's like stuff that I'm like I
grew up on I'm like you know how did all
this happen because I I have a band and
I had a band and we sold about 80
million uh Records less than you guys
sold
so uh that's that's a good one and I
know that it was very difficult
for me we just always I don't know any
band that hasn't gotten in fights hasn't
gotten like no this is cooler no this is
cooler and it would get some of these
fights were explosive like I'd be like
[ __ ] you get the [ __ ] out of my house
I [ __ ] don't I mean I and this was a
band that was nothing so I can't imagine
the pressures and the your guys are
making money and you're writing songs
together there's Egos and there's
I I don't know how you you lasted as
long as you did because I don't know one
band I was watching The Beatles
documentary you know and and uh one day
what's his name George Harrison just
goes okay well I think I'm going to quit
the band now
like what
that wasn't that wasn't a good career
choice but just but he did just fine
George did just fine no you know I think
Daryl and I both are very
non-confrontational people
um and we would rather you know kind of
just go our separate ways and just
let things simmer down and then figure
out a way a way around it um yeah it's
um it's you know it's it's really
amazing that we've been able to stay
together this year